so there is an oral history at the
athletic of the pursuit of peyton
manning once he was released by the
colts in 2012. a lot of teams were
interested he obviously landed with the
denver broncos
but
one of the things in the article that
caught my attention john elway who is
the gm of the broncos and successfully
landed peyton manning he told mike
shanahan who was coach in washington at
the time
that elway believed manning preferred
going to washington over denver
and it was the trade that was made while
all of this was happening and it's
almost like daniel snyder knew the only
way to stop this from happening
is to move up in the draft and position
himself to get robert griffin iii
that is what derailed it but you know we
all thought he wants to stay out of the
nfc he doesn't want to compete with eli
he wanted to go head-to-head with eli
twice per year chris
well i i think he was certainly thinking
about it you know my first thing is i
mean you're right i think daniel snyder
kind of sabotaged the whole thing from
happening
and made a deal with the rams to get the
number two pick to put them in position
to get rg3
without going through
i think mike shanahan so you know i
always had it like this that the story
was that peyton manning was at the
shanahan house
when they read on the ticker that the
redskins had traded to get the number
two pick now yesterday's story and
everything in the athletic revealed that
it was actually manning was in town so
maybe i had my facts mixed up but you
know i'm not shocked by that i don't
know if he ultimately would have pulled
the trigger but any you know of course
hey i know i'm biased and i know the
shanahan family and mike and kyle you
know but even for a guy like peyton
manning you know mike and kyle shanahan
are going to blow your socks off with
what they say to you football wise and
especially i can speak of kyle and i
know peyton referenced that in the
article talking about he was really
impressed with kyle because even for a
guy like peyton manning i guarantee kyle
said some things during that meeting
where he went oh that's a good idea whoa
i never thought about that on offense or
whatever it may be so i think he knew he
was going to be in a position to succeed
as a quarterback in washington
uh but he made the right choice and you
know ultimately do you really think he
would have wanted to go and deal with
his brother twice a year and have that
type of thing i i don't know i guess
that's where i question it
well the fact that it was even on the
table
tells me yes why do you you got every
team in the league practically chasing
you why are you going to waste your time
flirting with a team in your brother's
division unless you're regarding them as
a serious
destination because this wasn't about
leverage this was about him making his
choice and once he made his choice the
contract fell together this wasn't well
they're offering me this and they're
offering that who's giving me the best
deal he was making his choice
and it was implied right it was almost
like he had to be pre-authorized to show
up for the auction
whoever came to the table understood it
was going to be expensive he's deciding
who the buyer is going to be and then we
figure out what the price tag is the way
it's told in the story and again it's
excellent lengthy a lot of great nuggets
in there including jim harbaugh asking
david cut cliff's wife for a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich because he
didn't want to be rude because she
offered them food and it's like hey when
you know my mom when when my mom offered
somebody food you don't say yes they get
a little hurt so he took a pb and j but
uh um the the the
the way it went down as elway tells it
he was meeting with peyton manning when
it came in that the trade had happened
between washington and the rams to put
washington position to get rg3 oh okay
elway gleaned from peyton manning's
reaction oh my god he really wanted to
go there and and i i think he detected
from the other interactions that that
that's what peyton manning wanted and
peyton still met with the shanahan's the
next day even though the trade had
already been done and mike said in the
oral history at the athletic that that
he was he he thinks peyton was
disappointed by the fact that they had
made that trade and apparently mike and
kyle were disappointed too
yeah i you know i i think they
yeah you know i can remember back to the
time
and i remember kyle
you know questioning a little like hey
do you really think peyton would come
here you know and play with eli manning
you know play against eli twice a year
and you know kind of cancel each other
out to that degree i know they were
certainly questioning that uh but you
know i never had heard really peyton's
side of the story and yeah you know
again i think playing for the shanahan's
is quite appealing you know it's hard to
go back and find quarterbacks who
haven't had unbelievable numbers and
success you know playing
playing for kyle i mean that's what he's
done and i think peyton manning probably
realized that but ultimately
man he picked a really good one i mean
he did john elway did a great job of
getting some talent around him that
defense was there in place and he found
the right formula with adam gase to make
an offense work and they did some
special things going to two super bowls
and winning one of them so uh i don't
think he could be too disappointed with
the results
let's go alternate universe then yeah
peyton manning goes to washington they
don't give up ultimately three first
round picks and a second round pick to
get rg3
what happens for peyton manning over the
course of the next four years quickly
oh i mean i think the redskins and
washington are a different team i don't
know i'm not going to say they go to a
super bowl but they put up a lot of big
numbers and they're one of the best
teams in the nfc for sure i i have no
problem saying that
what about the shanahan's do
are they do they do they stay longer
than i think it was 2013 yeah of course
they do i mean that trade led to the
start of the dysfunction in washington
you know they start letting dan snyder
empowered rg3 to run the team i mean
it's like he gave him part ownership so
yeah i mean i think there's no doubt
about that that was the beginning of the
end right there so i think yes
everything ends up a lot better for the
shanahan family if they get peyton
manning down there
quick thought too if daniel snyder had
become infatuated with peyton manning
and had done the same thing you just
wonder how the balance of power would
have been
between peyton
and mike and kyle and maybe they're
eventually you know it starts off great
but eventually
peyton decides he wants it a certain way
mike and kyle wanted a different way and
there could have been some friction and
dysfunction there what about
uh rg3 where does he land i mean the
rams had the second overall pick but
they had sam bradford at the time i i
wonder who would have jumped on aj on
rg3 in the 2012 draft oh i know i well i
need to go back and look but i know
there's got to be some other teams there
in the top five that certainly were
quarterback needy that would have took a
chance on rg3 or not a chance i mean he
was a slam dunk no doubt about it
but no yeah i mean you know maybe the
cleveland browns don't take trent
richardson and rg3 is the quarterback
there you know that's the one pick i can
remember that would make sense anybody
else jump out to you mike as you're
looking that up
yeah i i uh
no um
and and
you know i try to put myself back in the
mindset of 2012 and it really was it
wasn't quite a peyton manning ryan leaf
debate because in 1998 that was a closer
discussion than people realize but there
were so i remember tony dungy saying
he'd take rg3 over andrew luck i mean
there were people who firmly believed in
rg3 as evidenced by the fact that
washington made the trade to get in
place to get him so i you know the the
the browns ended up that year
taking brandon whedon
late in the first right right now but
but uh but anyway um the vikings had
that third pick i wonder if the vikings
would have considered taking him but
they had christian ponder the year
before so probably not all right uh what
happened to tebow real quickly tebow tim
tebow stays with the broncos
if this ha if if peyton manning goes to
washington chris i doubt it i don't
think so i think john elway was gonna
get him out of there no matter what
because i think he saw a ceiling to
where that could go
i think john elway would have unretired
and played quarterback in 2012 if he had
to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports